- On this episode we
talk about outsourcing
everyday tasks, depth and width,
and how I react when
somebody asks for a selfie.
(hip hop music)
You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody.
This is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and this is episode 178
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
It's a very exciting day here at Vayner.
DRock, you can show it.
We'll give them a little
look on what's going on.
The big kids,
DRock, are you, these
are big cameras DRock.
I mean you're rolling
with a very small camera.
Is this making you feel insecure?
I mean these are big ass cameras DRock.
- [DRock] A little bit.
- You okay?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- India,
I know you were sick
and shoveled in.
- I know.
- I'm super excited you're feeling better.
- I feel much better.
- You excited to be back?
- Yes, very excited.
- Do you miss the show?
- Yeah, everyday.
- Good, thank you very much.
Alright, so let's get
into that show, India.
Let's go rocking and rolling.
We're on a tight sched today, but
a couple of, I wanna, I know, sorry.
I wanna talk about a couple things.
One, thank you guys so
much for all the love
on DailyVee.
Everybody is loving that.
DRock, this is really up,
your brand is through
the roof because of this.
People really believe that
you got a little bit of talent
now, and I'll be honest
will you, Staphon and India
have been talking.
You've changed.
You now think you're a big deal.
I'm just kidding.
Right?
- [India] Yeah.
- Is he trying to create
- [India] I'll have dinner and find out.
- Yeah, expose him a little bit.
Thank you guys all for that.
Super excited about the book,
the Snapchat stuff.
There's a lot we need to catch up on.
I feel very I have to go fast today
so we'll catch up in 179,
but there's a barter page.
We've got that going on,
the Snapchat thing we put
together was phenomenal.
The audiobook is done
and in the bag there will be an audiobook.
If you haven't been watching
Snapchat and DailyVee,
and I've enjoyed all the feedback from
so many of you that are missing
the #AskGaryVee Show.
Yes, a lot of you are
like ooh DailyVee is
now my favorite thing, and cool,
but a lot of my momentum for #AskGaryVee.
Just to make the
record straight, I will
continue to do the #AskGaryVee
Show, I've just been really busy.
The good news is DRock
is probably gonna travel
with me quite a bit for DailyVee
during the intensity that is gonna
be March and April with the new book,
and DRock we'll hack,
as a matter of fact we'll come up with
some side ideas
where people can be in
the India of the show,
because I don't think
we're gonna travel India.
Sorry India.
- Oh okay, that's fine.
It's cool. It's fine.
- Fine.
Oh, DRock, we gotta start micing India.
A lot of people are asking for that.
- [DRock] Yeah, I know.
Well that's what you guys
are supposed to be doing.
Don't I know me.
- [Staphon] I mean okay.
- Okay.
Alright India let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Chase asks, "Why
are so many people worried
"about their marketing ability while their
"product is plain awful?"
- Well Chase, I think this
comes down to something
that I call ugly child syndrome.
What I mean by that is
at some level, people are
very deep into their product.
They've spent time and years and money
developing their product,
and they're stuck.
They think that good
marketing or great marketing
can fix that product and service.
You're pandering if
you've watched me at all.
You're pandering to me right now,
because you know that I love to say
even the greatest marketing of all time
is not gonna fix your shit product.
I get it and I agree,
and I think the reason that
people are in that place
is it's less expensive
and seems more practical
to go and fix the
marketing over your product
than to scrap your whole business
and start creating a new charger
or a new sneaker, or a new shirt.
That seems like a reset,
whereas great marketing
feels like a renovation,
and most people want a patchwork,
and most people want a quick fix,
and it's just human behavior
that it's tough to take
a step back and say,
"Let's start all over."
That's just not a place where most
people wanna go, or can
they even practically
afford to go.
This is a very common problem for a lot
of businesses, and if you're
in that spot right now
I think you really have to
debate if you're better off
punting, going and getting a job
than going into more debt
or getting further along,
or the thing I think a lot more about,
and something I'll probably
pound a lot more in 2016
which is opportunity costs.
When do you cut bait
so that you can go onto
the next part of your life?
Because squeezing a rasin
for juice for another year
isn't gonna get you anything.
Thank you.
I'm feeling sharp today.
- [India] Nice.
- I feel really sharp.
I made the audiobook,
these guys.
I'm feeling really goddamn sharp.
- [Voiceover] Christine asks,
"What is the best way to
"bring awareness to your
brand when first starting up?"
- Christine
(gag)
I mean have you watched 170 something,
I mean there's a million
things you can do.
I mean PR is still a basic tried and true,
meaning like, show up on
blogs and be interviewed
and show up on a Blab,
and show up on a Periscope.
Things you can do without a PR company
and paying them two to five
thousand dollars a year.
Just hack, go on
I mean this is really,
this is almost tiresome.
What's her name?
- [India] Christine.
- Christine, I'm sorry, but
this is literally like, "Hey Gary,
"recap everything you've
been talking about for
"nine years."
I'd almost rather you just
Google my name and get
those answers this way, but I'll pander
to the context of the show.
I'm a little bit pissed off at you India
for this question.
This makes no sense.
There's a million things.
Create content, use social networks,
all of this stuff now doesn't cost money.
The reason I love social media is
it's layered on top of the internet,
and it doesn't cost you money.
It costs you talent and time,
but it doesn't cost you money.
Email Huff Po and say,
"I wanna guest blog."
Okay, and you talk about your stuff.
It's so easy.
Influencer, send them free product.
I have no idea what your
product or service is,
but there's so many ways to get exposure.
I get that I'm good at it,
but the blueprint has
been absolutely laid out
for so many people.
It's content creation,
and it's content and distribution
in it's most basic form.
Content and distribution.
The distribution game has changed so much
over the last decade.
The YouTubes and Facebooks and Twitters
and Snapchats, they all work if you know
how to use them.
It's a tool, right?
If I don't know how to use a wrench,
it's not valuable to me.
If you don't know how to use YouTube,
it won't be valuable to you,
but what you need to do is you need
to figure out how to make them valuable
or hire, or partner with somebody
that will make it valuable for you.
The ability to get exposure
now has never been easier.
The problem is that means everybody's
going into that game, and it
kilters the supply and demand
of attention.
Now everybody has got an at bat,
and now the cream has to rise to the top.
I don't know. Like that?
- [India] That was a
new perspective though,
all of that.
- [Gary] It wasn't super new, India.
- You used new analogies,
which is always helpful.
- That's different than perspectives.
- [India] Okay, fair.
From Andrew,
- Go ahead
Andrew
- [Voiceover] Andrew
asks, "What normal tasks
"do you outsource, for
example, preparing your meals,
"doing your laundry, etcetera
in order to enable you
"to focus on work?"
- I've outsourced
everything my whole life.
Either I outsource it or I punt it.
Since I was about in third grade
if I didn't think it was valuable to me
to buy the New York Jets, I've outsourced
or punted it.
School, couldn't outsource it,
couldn't say "Hey Brian Chen."
Real actual person, one of my best friends
in middle school.
"Hey Brian Chen, do my homework
"and take my test."
Couldn't do that so
instead I just took Fs.
Just punted it.
Sorry, I'm out.
Outsourcing, when I went to college
I was not capable of doing my own laundry
because my mom did everything for me
so I hacked, and
I mean this is kind of
awkward, but I would
get girlfriends to do it for me.
I would I guess hook up with girls
so they would do my laundry,
because there was no other way for me
to do my laundry, because to this day
as I sit here in front of
you as a 40 year old man
I've never done laundry in my life.
Now I know you're judging me,
and I respect that, but I'm judging you,
because I'm way better
at business than you are.
Listen, it's fair.
I think that there's
I mean I outsource every,
I don't wanna do anything.
I would never, ever, ever
do anything that I didn't wanna do
if I could help it.
I don't wanna change
my tire on the highway.
I have, because I was stuck,
but if there was a new
Uber-like app called
Tire where I could hit
it and in three minutes
somebody would be there, I would do that
every time.
I don't wanna do anything that I don't
wanna do, and I believe
everybody is the same way.
I've worked very hard to try to put myself
in the financial situation to do things,
including fixing my weight and my health,
because I needed somebody else to really
be full time for me to get there,
and then I'm just self-aware
about those things.
I don't want to, I don't care
how you judge me on
never doing my laundry.
I get it and I don't think that I'm right.
I just think it's my truth.
- [Voiceover] Corey asked,
"I might be the best example
"of someone who gets distracted
by width instead of depth.
"Do you ever have to regain focus?
"Tips?"
- Yeah, Corey.
You're talking about worrying
about how many followers
you have and how much reach you have,
and not worrying about if
you've positioned yourself
to actually convert on what you want to.
For me, my religion is depth, not width.
I don't struggle with that.
I never care about how
many Twitter followers
I have or how much traffic
I have to my website.
I'm always thinking about the moment
I'm gonna deal with in about a month
which is, did I sell books?
Did everything lead to that moment?
By the way, is it
February 23, my telethon?
- [India] Yes.
- February 23, get ready.
Oh we have to film the commerical for the
February 23.
Anyway February 23, mark
your calendar right now.
Actually, can we get
that on the calendar app
on GaryVaynerchuk.com?
We need to get that up.
From what?
10 AM to six,
yeah 10 AM to six PM
I'm doing a huge telethon where people
buy eight books and the whole thing.
It's gonna be huge.
Anyway,
I need to refocus on different things,
not the width and depth thing.
I need to refocus on opportunity cost.
This is gonna become my
you think you're tired of
me talking about Snapchat.
Wait til you hear how much I'm gonna pound
you in 2016 with opportunity cost,
because I'm becoming more self-aware
that my misses in my
career aren't necessarily
the things I'm doing.
They're the things I'm not doing, because
of the certain things I'm doing.
Got it?
I think that's what I'm
trying to focus myself on
which is putting myself in
the best position to succeed
and auditing my talents and my upside
to allocate my time and my efforts.
- [Voiceover] Travis
asks, "Do you lose respect
"for businesspeople if
they go all fangirl on you?
"Wanna take pics, etcetera?
"Do you feel respected or used?"
- I feel flattered.
I mean I don't, I defintely don't
I don't disrespect that.
It's the same way I
react to Brandon Marshall
or when you're into something,
you know, the great blessing of my life,
another nice thing that happened to me
was I'm in the prime of my career
when this entrepreneurship became
something people wanted to talk about.
I mean, for the things that I was taught
that I was a loser at from first
grade to 12th grade, has
now become the foundation
of people wanting to take selfies with me
on the streets of New York.
I do not disrespect somebody,
I don't feel like I,
first of all, you have
to understand how I roll.
I already think I have
an edge on all of you
so there's nothing to change.
If you ask me for a selfie
I don't think oh, now I got you.
I think I got you from the get.
I think I'm better than everybody
in that weird way when I put my
business uniform on.
I don't think it changes my
relationship that somebody
wants to do that.
I equally feel okay to do
that to a Jets offensive
lineman, because that's
the thing I'm passionate
and excited about.
For me the feeling is very simple.
I'm flattered, I'm humbled.
I actually think the people that like me
and are able to get through
my fascade of energy
and ego and bravado and
actually value my content
are quite smart and probably have a little
bit more EQ, and maybe that's my own
ego talking about myself,
but the truth is that's how I look at it.
I'm actually intrigued by my fan base.
A lot of people are always like,
you know how a lot of you are like,
"Man, you should have
more YouTube followers."
More people should know
Gary Vee, all this stuff
that you guys are so nice to me about.
I'm not so easy to figure out my friends.
We talk about this.
This is why I post on Instagram
"What was your first reaction to me?"
Because I want you guys,
it's not for me to feel
great about myself.
I already got that.
Check that box.
That's set for life.
It's for you to see how
other people reacted
to learn why this is all happening.
I'm a little bit of a contradiction.
I'm not so easy to figure out,
and so if somebody
comes up to me and says,
"I like your stuff."
The things that I default into,
the quick rush of emotion,
the blood that rushes to my head is like,
"Holy crap."
Number two is like, "Did
anybody else see this?
"Did India see this,
see how popular I am?"
Number three is, huh this
person is interesting.
They were able to figure it out.
Why?
Those are the things that tend to rush
to my head.
Great, good show.
Good show right?
Yeah, it's fun.
Question of the day.
Who's gonna win the Superbowl?
And why is the fun one.
And number two, because I haven't
been doing the show that much
and I need comments, they're my oxygen.
I love your audit on episode 10 and 11
of the DailyVee.
You keep asking questions.
I'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)